good evening
good evening everyone my name is craig
spence the ipc chief brand and
communications officer
welcome to this press conference
regarding the outcomes of the ipc
governing board meeting from earlier
today
joining me on the top table this evening
to my left is the ipc president andrew
parsons
next to him is yetzka visser
the chairperson of the ipc athletes
council
and to the far left is dwayne kale
the
vice president of the international
paralympic committee
the format for this evening's press
conference you'll have obviously seen
the decision that was communicated at
1915 local time this evening is andrew
will say some words about how the board
reached that decision
we will then pass the floor to yitzke to
say some words on behalf of the athlete
community
and then we will open the floor for
questions
andrew the floor is yours
thank you very much crain
you're all thank you for joining us here
so late this evening and all to those of
you joining this press conference online
i would much prefer to be talking to you
this evening about paralympic athletes
the outstanding sport you are about to
witness
and how fantastic the preparations are
going here for beijing 2022 paralympic
winter games
however
with just 48 hours to go before the
opening ceremony of the beijing 2022
paralympic winter games
this is a very difficult time for the
whole world as well as the paralympic
movement
this week the ipc has needed to navigate
its way through two
very difficult issues
the safe passage of the ukrainian
paralympic team to beijing
and the breach of the olympic truths by
the russian and belarus governments
it goes without saying
that the ongoing situation in ukraine is
horrific
and our thoughts prayers and well-wishes
are with our member the npc of ukraine
its delegates athletes officials and the
wider ukrainian population
i am delighted to say that just hours
ago the ukrainian team consisting of 20
athletes and nine guides
arrive safely here in beijing
this is a wonderful achievement and i'm
sure you share my delight
that they are safe and will be able to
compete at these games
for this i would like to thank the ipc
management team and the beijing 2022
organizing committee for their tireless
work behind the scenes
today the ipc governing board met to
discuss the current situation and
its impact on the paralympic games
and the wider paralympic movement
as you can imagine it was a very intense
and emotional meeting with all board
members eager to share their views on
the matter at hand
over the last week the board and myself
have also had many conversations with
ipc members and we are all grateful to
you
for sharing your views and your opinions
on this subject
the points raise both publicly and
privately
by our member organizations fed into the
internal discussions we had over the
course of the last several days
the 14 strong board which features eight
paralympians was united in his
combination of both
russian and belarus governments for
breaching the un resolution in the week
leading up to the opening of the games
the board was also unanimous in deciding
that such actions could not go unnoticed
or unaddressed
in deciding what action to take the
board was guided by the ipc's core
principles
which include a commitment to political
neutrality and impartiality and then
unwavering belief in the transformative
power of sport
these are key components of the new ipc
constitution that was approved at the
2021 ipc general assembly held just over
three months ago
the board also needed to work within the
framework of the ipc handbook
the rules and regulations that govern
the paralympic movement and which are
approved by the ipc membership
in that respect it is currently another
membership obligation for an ipc member
to ensure compliance with the olympic
truths
we were also conscious that decisions of
this magnitude invariably end up in law
courts
therefore our decision making needed to
be driven not by emotions but by our
constitutional purpose and handbook
this approach is consistent with how we
tackle the russian doping crisis ahead
of the real 2016 paralympic games
back then we were able to prove that the
rpc was unable to ensure compliance with
and the enforcement of the ipc's
anti-doping code and the world untied
open code
these obligations are a fundamental
requirement for all national paralympic
committees and clearly
highlighted in the ipc handbook
this time around the situation is
different
there is no nexus between the recent
actions of the russian and belarusian
governments and our membership
obligations
in particular there currently is no
membership obligation for an ipc member
to ensure compliance with the olympic
truce this means that within the current
ipc rules framework so spending either
npc russia or npc belarus for breaching
the olympic truths
is something that would be overturned in
the german court of law
working within the parameters of the ipc
constitution and the ipc handbook the
ipc governing board has taken the
stronger possible action in response to
the gross violation of the olympic truce
by the governments of russia and belarus
the actions we have taken were announced
earlier this evening ahead of them
becoming public we informed beijing 2022
the ioc and briefed all ipc members
participating in the beijing 2022
paralympic winter games
the measures are as follows
the rpc and pc belarus will participate
as neutrals at the beijing 2022
paralympic winter games under the
following conditions
all their athletes support personnel who
participate in an individual capacity as
neutral athletes support personnel
they will compete under the paralympic
flag and the paralympic end them
they will not be included in the metals
table
the rpc delegation must cover their rpc
symbol on their uniforms in all official
ceremonies and sporting competitions
the belarus delegation must cover the
belarus flag on the uniforms in all
official ceremonies and sporting
competitions
all technical officials attending the
games from russian belarus will be
listed as neutrals under the paralympic
flag as real coaches from the respective
countries involved with other teams
the approach set out on points one and
two above will also be followed in
relation to the participation of the rpc
and npc belarus in the 10 paris votes
governed by the ipc
the ipc governing board has also decided
both in its role as the global guardian
of paralympic movement and as
international federations for 10 paris
sports that it will not hold any events
in russia or belarus until further
notice
this will include world and european
championships as well as all sanctions
level competitions
such as world series world cups and
grand prix events
the ipc governing board also recommends
that all parasport international
federations region organizations and the
irsds follow the same approach
an extraordinary ipc general assembly
will be held in 2022
and the ipc constitution six months
notice must be given before this event
can take place at this meeting ipc
members will be invited to vote upon
whether ensuring compliance with the
olympic truths should be a membership
requirement and therefore
any ipc member breaching that
requirement in the future could face
suspension or termination under the ipc
rules
and whether to suspend or terminate the
membership of the russian paralympic
committee and belarus paralympic
committee
the paralympic owner bestotto vladimir
putin president of russia has been
withdrawn
paralympic orders the highest accolade
can be presented within the paralympian
movement we will be withdrawn from the
following individuals
dimitri cernichenko president of sochi
2014 organizing committee now deputy
prime minister of the russian federation
dmitry kozak the puti prime minister of
russia now deputy chief of staff of the
presidential executive office oleg cito
molotov
chief of interagency security command
center sochi 2014
now deputy foreign minister
alexander golovoy deputy chief of
interagency security command center
sochi 2014 now first deputy interior
minister
given the time constraints and the need
for the apc to focus on the delivery of
a safe and successful paralympic winter
games under these unprecedented
circumstances
the ipc governing board will reconvene
after the games to further discuss this
matter and any additional action that
may be required
it is deeply disappointing that such
action is required
however the apc governing board believes
it to be necessary in order to hold
governments to account for actions that
impact directly on the paralympic
movement the paralympic games and
paralympic athletes
this is especially so given the origins
of the paralympic movement arising out
of the horrific events of second world
raw
now that this decision has been made i
expect all participating npcs to treat
the neutral athletes as they would any
other athletes at these games no matter
how difficult this may be
unlike their respective governments
these paralympic athletes and officials
are not aggressors they are here to
compete in a sport event like everybody
else
the eye of the world will be watching
the paralympic winter games in the
coming days it is vital we show the
world leaders through our sport that we
can unite as human beings and that our
true power is final when we promote
peace understanding and inclusion
this is at the core of what the
paralympic movement does and what it
stands for
we should not lose sight of this now no
matter what the circumstances
in some of my conversations during the
past several days i've heard the
sentiment that sometimes you just have
to do the right thing no matter what the
consequence
i suspect some of you in this room may
be thinking the same i want to take a
moment to address this view because i
think it is misplaced in these
circumstances and actually can result in
real damage to our movement
the question i will ask is the right
thing for whom
the second thing i offer is that being
faithful to our constitution and
membership obligations is in fact doing
the right thing
with our membership and our
constitutional purpose our collective
belief in the power of sport it's not
something that we put on and take off
whenever it suits us
instead the principle of political
neutrality and genuine belief in the
transformative power of sport must be
our north star
our strength or perhaps our lifeboat
especially when we find ourselves facing
the darker side of humanity
these commitments are ones to embrace
not shed
during these critical times
to close i hope i have been able to
share with you the difficulty of today's
decision at the ipc we pride ourselves
on sticking to our principles when
making difficult decisions
today we could not abandon the
principles that have got us this far no
matter what the public pressure
as a membership-based organization we
value the views and the ongoing support
of our members
this is why we are eager to organize
this extraordinary general assembly
later this year rather than wait until
2023 general assembly so that the
members can have more of a say on this
matter
thank you
thank you andrew i'd now like to pass
the mic to yitzger
fissa the chairperson of the ipc
athletes council yes over to you
thank you craig
good evening everyone as the chairperson
of the ipc athletes council it's
disappointing for the athletes and all
game stakeholders that with 48 hours to
go before the opening ceremony the talk
is not of sport but global politics
we've also been greatly concerned to
ensure that the ukrainian paralympic
delegation could safely get to the games
and it is wonderful that they arrived
earlier this day
since this crisis began
the ipc athletes council has been eager
to listen to the views of the global
global para athlete community in
particular the 647 athletes who are
competing here in beijing
interestingly the views are strongest
amongst those athletes who are not here
in beijing those from sports not here to
compete within the next days
for those athletes competing here in
beijing the views are very mixed
regardless i think it is really
important for all athletes to be free to
voice their opinion on this matter it's
important and crucial that their voice
is heard
for the athletes here at the beijing
2022 paralympic winter games it's
important that athletes voice their
views within the rules that they have
helped shape following an 18-month long
consultation
this means the freedom to share their
opinions with the media and the public
via social media
in my role as chairperson of the ipc
athletes council it is my responsibility
to summarize all the views to the of the
athlete community on this situation and
present him to the ipc governing board
the ipc aims to be an
an athlete-centered organization and at
a board level 8 of the 14 members are
paralympians who between them have 23
paralympic games dating from 18
sorry 1984
through tokyo 2020
one consistent view from the athlete
community is that every athlete should
be treated fairly
i truly believe the ipc governing
board's decision today achieves this
in the meeting it was a very in-depth
and lengthy discussion and i think the
decision made is the right one
being a part of the paralympic movement
and the paralympic games means being a
part of something bigger than each of us
these games empire sport itself show the
world the transformative nature of sport
to unite people and promote peace
we have athletes here in our care who
have trained for many many years to
reach the very pinnacle of their
respective sports
which are these paralympic winter games
this is something many have dedicated
their lives to
as a four-time paralympian myself
representing my country on the biggest
stage of always the greatest of honors i
chose her every
paralympic games i am part of and
therefore i'm always fully committed to
make the most of the opportunity
for some athletes to come here and
decide not to compete is something i
really believe they will regret for the
rest of their lives
this may be their only opportunity to
compete at the biggest stage and if you
don't compete
then you'll make it easier for other
athletes to win
not competing against an opponent goes
against these principles and against the
values of fair play and sportsmanship
that have served the paralympic movement
so well since its inception in 1948
the paralympic movement prides itself on
celebrating diversity embracing
differences and discouraging
discrimination
to finish
i hope now that the decision has been
made the focus can switch back to sport
our hosts and many athletes have been
preparing for this event for several
years now let's show the world what we
can do
being united thank you
thank you yitzka we will now open the
floor
to questions so if you have your
question please raise your hand
and i think is the format that you go to
the microphone in the middle of the uh
the channel here so if anyone has any
questions please raise your hand and i
will invite you to go to the microphone
take the gentleman here
so my name is lee rini i am a journalist
with the kiev post in ukraine
uh i also have been writing for the ipc
since 2017.
mr parsons i was very much looking
forward to meeting you
this is
not easy
for
anyone in ukraine right now
this wasn't what i was supposed to be
doing here
i'm a journalist an english language
journalist in the country
no other journalists were allowed to
travel out of the country
they're not allowed
even if they wanted to
my first question and and please forgive
me i do have a couple because there's no
other ukrainians here
to ask these questions
my first question
is i want to know what you would say
to yevhin malashev's parents
is a
was
a biathlete on the on ukraine's national
junior team
he was killed yesterday
he was killed yesterday in a bombing in
haruki
you talked earlier
about
giving athletes the chance to compete
he will never get a chance to compete
again
so on behalf of his family i want to
know
what you would say to them about
allowing athletes from the aggressor
states to compete when he will never get
that chance
well the only thing i can say to his
family is that
of course we regret what is going on in
ukraine
i cannot even start to imagine the pain
that this family
is feeling at the moment
again my country is not at war my family
is not protecting themselves from
bombings in the subways of kiev as i
know that many people are doing at the
moment
so i cannot it's very i cannot even
start to imagine the pain that they are
feeling right now so okay only tell them
that my deepest thoughts are with them
my prayers
and unfortunately they will not see
their son competing
here in beijing and this is absolutely
not fair
it's disgusting it's against humanity
but again the decision that we took was
based in our constitution we do not
believe that by not following the rules
and regulations of the international
paralympic committee which the
laws that makes us viable and possible
as an organization and as a movement
that took us this far
will ever uh
change what what is going
what happened with their son
unfortunately
russian athletes competing here is
neutrals not competing here's newton's
will not change what happened
and this is a crime against humanity
while we're seeing here so i can only
sympathize with them try to
try to i cannot even imagine how they
should be feeling at the moment and for
not seeing him competing at the highest
possible level here
no one is happy
no one here is
thinks that what is happening in ukraine
is normal or even acceptable
but again we do have to follow the rules
of our own organization
uh under the risk
of having our decisions overturned we
cannot we don't have the authority to
ban
the russian and belarus athletes
but the general assembly has that's why
we are calling an extraordinary journal
similar to dude
so i apologize
but
this seems to be a rehash of what
happened eight years ago
when russia was the
host of the paralympic games
and first invaded ukraine
this isn't a new war this has been going
on for eight years
you're talking about
introducing legislation
or bylaws to deal with breaking the
olympic truce
can you
explain why this wasn't done when they
did this in the first place eight years
ago
no i don't think i have an explanation
that for that fact why in 2014
it was not introduced
any legislation to say that the olympic
truce was not
when it's broken it was a member it was
a breach of the membership obligations
of any country i cannot explain you
why that was not the case
and i know it's not only the second time
it's the third time that russia breaches
the the
olympic truths
but this is the same war that's the
sorry this is the same war as
twenty-four it's the same more as
this word is not something new it has
escalated to a completely new level but
it's going on for eight years i agree
with you
uh
the last question i have here
i'm just wondering
how vigorously how vigorously will the
ipc enforce its ban on protesting
for example will federations be
penalized
for their athletes refusing to p to
compete against athletes from the
aggressor states
the first thing can you repeat the last
part of your question sorry
will federations be penalized for their
athletes refusing to compete against
athletes from the aggressive states
the only difference i would like to make
in the last part of your question and i
do understand that russia is aggressive
state
but the athletes here
that were born in that nation
they are not the aggressors
and i think it's important to make that
distinction
i agree with you they are from the
aggressive state
but the athletes here
they are not
soldiers they are not the aggressors and
i think we need to treat them with the
same respect we treat athletes from any
other nation who earn the qualifications
lot to be here
specifically on your question we will
act when
and as it happens you know i think
hypothetical situations it's difficult
to articulate on that
but we will deal uh with that when and
as they happen
and what is your name can you can you li
rini
li rini
look again
i cannot even
imagine
how painful it is
to be ukrainian now
i try to sympathize i try to empathize
it's difficult i'm my country's not a
war again my family is not hiding
themselves in the subways of the capital
of my nation
we do recognize the seriousness and the
magnitude of the situation
we just tried to separate politics from
sport
we do not believe that
the response
to the russian government will be to ban
their athletes
not respecting our own constitution if
they break the rules
of the international laws we will not
break our own laws we cannot do that
but we do understand how painful we try
to understand how painful it is to be
ukrainian these days
that's why we made a huge effort
together with ukrainian paralympic
committee to bring the athletes here
because
the president of the ukrainian
paralympic committee
he said to me two things of course he
said look we would like to see
the athletes from belarus and russia out
and they said look i respect that
valerie
and he said but our athletes want to
compete
and then we made a huge effort to bring
them here
together with them together with ukraine
all the credit ukrainian paralympic
committee to the ipc especially the
ukrainian paralympic committee
i hope they are able to share with you
share with the world their journey to
get here it's a fantastic
it's a fantastic piece of uh
of human resistance and resilience
things that only can happen most
probably at the paralympic games while
these athletes are doing to compete here
it's outstanding it's their heroes just
to be here
but again
we cannot because of that recognizing
all the effort recognizing what is going
on to not follow our own rules
otherwise where do we draw the line in
the future and i do understand your
feelings i do respect them um i see
you're wearing with pride the national
colors of ukraine you should do that and
this is what we would like to see the
ukrainian athletes here competing
winning losing as it happens with every
sportsman in the world
but
honoring the colors of their country
which is something
as you said athletes who were born
in the
state aggressor state they will not have
the opportunity and this is something
that i think they will regret
but is up
to their government to explain to them
why they will not do that
but i do
respect your pain and your emotions
right now
thank you lee
do we have any further questions we're
carco just here
thank you wakako yuki from yamirishim
president
um one
first question
is a uh small follow-up
i think you just mentioned uh
talking to valerie i mean mr ciscovich
was it time after you made a decision
you have already communicated to you
claim and delegate no
we have communicated to all the national
paralympic committees
in writing i haven't spoke with valerie
since we took the decision i spoke with
him a few days ago i was not even in
china when we spoke because of
they started this
journey to be here and valerie is with
his athletes so no i haven't not i
haven't spoken with him we will speak
tomorrow
of course with all the respect to what
you have gone through today the heavy
decision um but it seems to me that um
the ipc is asking ukraine and athlete
to peacefully compete
in the competition while
knowing that their
families and cities could be
in imminent danger
from governmental aggressors
are you do you believe that it's
humanely possible for your parents
i think these athletes they have fought
the battle of their lives to be here not
only in the last few weeks to qualify
but just their journey to be here
i do not believe the ukrainian athletes
they are coming here to be aggressive
with athletes from russia or belarus i
think they are coming here to compete
and to make ukrainians proud in this
very difficult moment in the history of
the nation so i think and i'm
absolutely sure that they if they did
what they
they did all of that to be here is to
compete
and make their counter proud and not to
fight against athletes and not be
aggressive and not be
if they can be aggressive while
competing
and and put all the strength all the
anger in having the best possible
performance and taking all this
frustration
yes that's that's that's what i think
they should do
but they should not waste the
opportunity something that they have
fought so hard
to do exactly what the aggressor wants
them to do
which is to have you know lose their
mind and do something that they regret
for the rest of their lives the
yetzka has mentioned here the pinnacle
the moment of their lives it's here at
the paralympic winter games so i do
believe that they will focus on that i
hope they will do that understanding
against their pain their frustration
and that when they see
um athletes from belarus and russia
of course we understand that that
feeling will be negative but we hope
as top pathways that they are that they
can focus on the competition
karko just to add on to that i think
in the paralympic movement we always
talk about human resilience
and
i think the ukrainian delegation being
here is is the greatest example of human
resilience we've ever seen in the
paralympic movement
we always talk always about as well as
as challenges as being opportunities
and we have the world's eyes on us right
now
they may not be agreeing with the
decision
but if we can show unity in people and
use this platform
to promote the fact that we can bring
athletes from 48 different nations
to come here and compete together in
peaceful circumstances
and show that when you set rules you
abide by them
i think that sends out a very strong
message to the world leaders
and we need to do that what we can't do
what we can't do just because others are
is is run away from our moral
obligations and and and the rules of
what we've set i mean if we start
breaking our own rules
then then what hope is there for for
competition in sport we just tear up the
rule book we've got to stick
to the to the
core principles
that have got the paralympic movement to
where we are today and one of those is
fighting discrimination
and promoting inclusion that's what we
need to do here
and by bringing the nations together we
we've got to send out a really strong
message of peace because that's what the
world needs right now
it needs peace
question from the back there
my name is john santos from radio canada
i've been covering the games since 2008
here in beijing
my question is for the athlete's
representative
you said that you have the
responsibility to represent all the
opinions
that these opinions were very mixed
did you talk to the ukrainian athletes
and how did they react when they knew
when they learned that they would face
athletes from russia and belarus
thank you for your question
[Music]
i was able to talk to the ukrainian
athletes before this decision was made
so we did not know what was going to
happen
um so i did take their uh opinion into
consideration and i also brought it to
the board and the decision only has been
made this afternoon
so after that i have not been able to
speak with them yet and i am hoping to
be speaking to them tomorrow
i think just to answer that is
do you think it will be well received
well to be honest i do not know that how
they are going to react
i
would love to get back to you tomorrow
when i have their answer
look i think
we all appreciate difficult decisions
and never
universally accepted we totally knew
that when the board was making the
decision today but as yitzca said one of
the themes that was coming out from all
the conversations of the athlete
community
was to treat athletes fairly
and that's what we've tried to do today
there's a there's been a lot of talk in
sport in many years and for the last few
years about athlete welfare
we have two delegations here who have
trained for four years
to be at this moment
where if we were to send them home now
just because of their leaders
through no choice of the athletes
that i think is not right
what we've done
is
the the harshest possible possible
punishment we can do within the
framework of our rules
if we'd have banned russia today
all that would have happened
is tomorrow
they'd have gone to the courts
and then we'd have seen the rpc
competing in there as the rpc in the
medals table
and we would have seen the belarus
national paralympic committee competing
as they were
this decision ensures mutual paralympic
athletes those athletes can can compete
as an individual
and that's what we've tried to do today
is listen to the athletes who said
treat
people fairly that's what we're asking
for in the paralympic movement we want
people to be treated fairly in society
it's what we fight for every single day
that's our cause that's our purpose
but as i say the difficult decisions are
never going to be usually firstly
accepted
and we just have to face that
unfortunately today
any further questions
question from
this gentleman here
my name is masaki paraya from kodo news
ask questions in japanese
no it was not unanimous
we had different opinions that went from
not taking any action to banning russian
atheists but the vast majority of our
boat have decided
what we are announcing here
in this occasion
no that is not something that we do a
decision made by the ipc governing board
is a decision that it's uh defended by
the whole group we we can we do not
disclose if it's three votes ten votes
uh what i can say is that it was not
unanimous because you asked but that we
don't disclose the number of votes and
we don't say who voted for what is a
group decision
yes some some members have expressed
their view but at the end of the
discussions
the vast majority voted for the measure
that we are communicating this evening
foreign
yes they if they win medals they will
get the medals
if they get the gold medal there will be
a ceremony with the paralympic flag the
paralympic anthem but do you not see
that added to the medal table anywhere
because the npa
is not and and
the two
neutral uh teams they are not
participating as teams
there is a new group of neutral neutral
athletes so you not see them in the
metal table
yes athletes will receive the
when we say that it's not going to be in
the metal table they were not acting as
a team
so you'll not see that in the middle
table but yes the medal will be handled
to the athlete
thank you very much welcome
and just on a technicality the the rpc
will be npa neutral paralympic athletes
and npc belarus will be known as pna
paralympic mutual athletes so we need to
do the three
letter coding in order for the result
system but neither of those delegations
or those codes will appear on the medals
table
do we have any further questions
we have a question from the back there
and then we'll come over here
thank you very much uh hiroki torah from
assaf chamber thank you for taking my
question uh question to the president
and the chair of athlete council
i know there's not much time
to the opening ceremony but will there
be an opportunity for you to explain
directly to the athletes before the uh
the game starts
the athletes are validations you mean
yes yes
well
before coming here we spoke with the npc
the president and secretary general's of
the national paralympic committees
present here
tomorrow morning we will be at the
shepherd mission meeting to speak with
the shepherd mission uh we will not have
the opportunity to put all the athletes
together to explain to them we're doing
this through the national paralympic
committees we're doing that through the
chapter mission so the leader of the
the
respective teams here in beijing uh of
course the athletes normally reach out
to the to the uh athletes council but
any athlete that wants uh to sit and
talk and understand better we are open
to that again we are very democratic
very transparent that's why we're here
tonight to explain uh but there is no
opportunity and they are in three
different villages
to have all the others gathered to
explain that to them
thank you very much thank you the
question over here to the left-hand side
hi i'm taku from nhk um
thank you for the opportunity to have to
have a
question
man
foreign
in the opening ceremony there will be as
neutral so no flag from
rpc
and no flag from uh
national paralympic committee of belarus
i didn't get and doesn't really
understand your question on on on the
numbers but that's i think is it
from what i understood your question yes
we will have 46
national paralympic committees on the
medal table
the two npa is just a a way of grouping
them
because you have to to attribute a code
a national code a code of three letters
to every single letter but their results
will not be grouped you will not see in
the metal table npa x number of gold
medals
gold silver and bronze you'll not see
that
their team does not exist here
their team does not exist here but we do
believe that individual athletes who
have earned their qualification to these
games they have the right to compete
here
question from the middle here
hi david wallenstein new york times i'm
just wondering all these other
organizations that have banned the
russian athletes
fifa uefa formula one etc
they've made what what
has
separated you do you think from all
those other organizations is it just the
principle of your rules i mean do they
not have those similar rules
every organization has its own
constitution its own rules
uh and of course we are based in germany
so we are governed by german law some of
these organizations you mentioned they
are based sorry in different nations so
they are governed by different laws
i
do you know i'm just curious if you know
offhand if
they have similar things and they just
decided you know what we're going to ban
them anyway
i don't have the information
in what they have base
of the suspensions or
let's say the legal basis for them to do
that because at the end of the day they
have their own constitution their own
rules and regulation different from ours
or not but that we do believe that we
are following our own rules our own
regulations and the rules and the law of
the country we are based on
could i just ask the three board members
if
when you have the the
meeting
to determine how you should go forward
in the future
whether you will vote that a breach of
of the truce
is something that would warrant being
kicked out of the games in the future
we do not vote
as board members we do not vote
but if you ask me if i had a vote
yes i would
do we have any further questions
okay we go just here and then with carco
we come to you and then we close hello
i'm journalist from latvia by baronza i
wanted to ask
if
other athletes from other countries are
allowed to show their support for
ukrainian people and somehow in flags or
symbolic
or will there be so some consequences
against them for showing support
yeah i can answer that one so so we have
uh rules which have been produced
following 18 months of consultation with
the ipc athletes council
those rules are very transparent they're
available on the ipc website under the
beijing 2022 uh home page
and the rules from our the views from
our athletes council and and also from
the athlete community when we did this
consultation process before tokyo
was that the field of play
the podium
and the ceremonies
should be protected from any form of of
what could be classed as a protest or
sharing the views which is slightly
outside of
that would be waving flags and such like
however if athletes want to share their
views in the media
and via social media and show their
support there
that's all well within the rules of what
we have here
yeah but this is not ordinary situation
and you said it that uh
people should be united
and uh i get that but what we've also
said today is that we've made a decision
that's based on our rules
and here we've got to stick to the rules
again what we can't do in this situation
is just say look
we abandon our our core principles that
got our movements where we are the rules
are there
we need to keep them in place but what
we're saying is that athletes can share
their views by all means in media mix
zones press conferences social media
but the athlete community told us during
an 18-month consultation
please protect the field of play
please protect the podium and please
protect the ceremonies
from any form of of protest
so we've got to listen to the athletes
there
and we when we did the consultation with
the athletes we gave them a whole range
of scenarios
which included
the war
and the the the the view was
protect those areas so again we've got
to listen to the athletes here and we've
got to enforce the rules that we spent
18 months consulting with the athlete
community on
thank you
okay we've got wicarco and then you sir
will be the last question
sorry one um no two technical uh
follow-ups please uh to president
uh you said there's no team will
russians be allowed to russian well a
russian
based
individual athlete will be allowed to
participate in
ice hockey as a team and if so what
could be their team name
well the as craig has mentioned the
in neutral paralympic athletes and the
paralympic neutral athletes
as a team
they were competing team supports they
will compete yeah so um you talk about
future
extraordinary assembly general assembly
and
my understanding of course is that even
if you would decide at the time to
create some kind of cloud
to
make it mandatory for
any membership
to
follow the olympic truth in the future
that cannot be
applicable to what happened here so in a
way you cannot use that ground
to ban
russia or below
npcs
in a legal term am i correct to
understand so yes we cannot recorrect we
cannot uh approve and this is needs to
be approved by our general assembly we
cannot approve a new rule and
retroactively apply them to suspend or
terminate membership of any member i see
and if governing board cannot
punish
russia no belarusian npc
although it seems that constitution does
have some clout for governing board to
suspend their membership
do you
think that when it comes to general
assembly and you
discuss about
the suspension of russian or belarusian
npc at that time
do you have or your general assembly
membership have any ground
to
decide
upon it the general assembly has the
right to suspend or terminate membership
in a different way
compared to what the board can do
we can only make that decision to
suspend we cannot terminate membership
but we can suspend if there is a breach
of the membership obligations
and there was
again the breach of the olympic truce is
not a membership uh it's not against a
membership obligation so we as the ball
we cannot suspend
uh any of these npcs now
that's what we want to change in the
future but we cannot make that change to
our own constitution only the general
assembly can
thank you for the clarification
thank you akako final question erin
devin harun with cbc sports for
president persons just moments ago
ukrainian athletes have issued a joint
statement
saying with bombs raining down on
ukrainian citizens the decision made by
the ipc today is another blow
to ukrainian athletes and citizens how
do you respond to that
well i do understand their feelings and
do understand
they they are coming from a counter that
is at war
we do understand their emotions we do
understand their reactions
the situation here is that we as a board
we cannot
make our decisions based on our emotions
and our reactions
we will put this organization at risk
what i will respond to them is that the
best
way that they can express
their pride in being ukrainians
is to do what they do best which is
compete at the highest possible level in
the field of play here in beijing i
think this is the way they can express
the strength of ukrainian people is
winning as many medals as possible in
the field of play here in beijing this
is what i will tell them i understand i
sympathize
i can only imagine the pain you know i
never experienced anything even close to
what they have experienced
so i do understand and sympathize with
their feelings
but we do have a responsibility here and
what i would like to
tell them i encourage them is that they
put all this energy into the field of
play and again make ukraine proud
okay we will bring tonight's press
conference to a close apologies for the
late evening
we look forward to seeing you during the
rest of the games thank you very much
and have a good evening
foreign